[Música]
[Aplausos]
hace algunos años mi objetivo a graduar
una universidad era el de desempeñarme
en el sector petrolero objetivo que
cumplí en 2014 cuando fue contratado por
halliburton una de las compañías de
servicios petroleros más importantes a
nivel global la transición de ese
trabajo de perforación de pozos en
situaciones altamente demandantes hacia
la industria de la inversión y gestión
de activos ocurrió cuando leí los libros
el inversor inteligente de benjamin
graham y un paso por delante de
wallstreet de peter lynch ambos libros
me abrieron la puerta a lo que luego se
convertiría en mi pasión y mi estilo de
vida el balís best
siempre había sentido curiosidad por las
finanzas los mercados y las inversiones
así que en ese momento continúa leyendo
docenas de libros que me dieron la
claridad y la determinación que
necesitaba para seguir mi pasión me
retiré de halliburton en 2016 y unos
cuantos meses después fundé mi primera
consultora financiera
en los últimos cinco años tras seguir
acumulando experiencia en los mercados y
habiendo finalizado mi maestría en
financia en el ies ha extendido mi
cruzada de concientización sobre la
importancia de las finanzas entre los
venezolanos por ello cree el primer club
de lectura financiera en venezuela y que
hoy ya cuenta con más de 1.400 miembros
en todo el país y además funde
paralelamente una escuela de inversión
que a día de hoy cuenta con más de 600
estudiantes en toda venezuela hoy por
hoy mi objetivo sigue alineado con la
construcción de comunidades y de
iniciativas que permitan cambiar la
mentalidad financiera de los venezolanos
a partir del debate y el intercambio de
ideas la cual creo es la mejor forma de
promover un cambio en el país
como les comentaba gracias a la lectura
descubrí mi pasión en el bario investing
y siempre he pensado que es muy fácil
entender al bario investing si lo
definimos como cualquier inversión
inteligente como suele decir charlie
münger toda inversión inteligente es
value investing adquirir algo por menos
de lo que vale pero a pesar de lo
relativamente sencillo que suele ser
leer sobre value investing entender sus
principales premisas y fundamentos y de
hecho ver que le ha permitido a un grupo
de inversionistas ser altamente
rentables en wall street muy pocas
personas toman esto en cuenta esto
siempre ha sido así y posiblemente
siempre lo sea pero verdaderamente es
una ventaja para nosotros
en teoría el value investing es muy
simple con este como base mi idea es
buscar acciones con descuento con este
como premisa mi idea es armar un
portafolio de compañías donde el
descuento en relación al valor
intrínseco sea el principal atributo en
la práctica digamos que el cálculo de lo
que vale una empresa es un proceso
medianamente complicado que implica
proyectar sus flujos de caja en el
futuro y descontar los a una tasa de
descuento apropiada pero vamos con un
ejemplo un poquito más aterrizado para
empezar a entender realmente de qué va y
vale un best
imaginemos que el sector inmobiliario
turístico de tu país está actualmente
atravesando una crisis eso significa que
la mayoría de las casas en la playa
están a buen precio y parece un buen
momento para comprar después de realizar
un análisis exhaustivo histórico y
comparativo del sector e incluso
comparando con inmuebles de la misma
línea en otros países te das cuenta que
tu situación financiera te permite
comprar la casa vacacional de tus sueños
a precio de ganga elabora un presupuesto
organiza tus ahorros y acomete la compra
del inmueble
una vez pasado el tiempo pasada la
crisis el valor de tu casa se va a
revalorizar y en ese momento vas a tener
dos muy buenas opciones primero podrás
estar muy feliz puede comprarse un
activo por mucho menos de lo que vale y
disfrutar de la casa en la playa con tus
amigos y familiares y segundo
podrías si tus prioridades cambiaron
vender la casa recuperar la inversión
hacer dinero y destinar ese ahorro a
otro objetivo que tenga en mente como
vemos durante todo este proceso dos
premisas son fundamentales una ser
paciente y dos tener un horizonte de
inversión a largo plazo pero antes de
entrar en detalles sobre qué realmente
evaluarlo investing hagamos un repaso
histórico por esta filosofía
el value investing fue inicialmente
incorporado alrededor de en 1928 por
benjamin graham y débito a ambos
profesores de la escuela de negocios de
la universidad de columbia en eeuu
granja y dos fueron coautores en 1934
del libro sécurité análisis el cual es
considerado la piedra fundacional del
análisis instrumentos financieros pero
más que nadie
benjamin graham es realmente el
considerado padre del value investing en
1949 tras haría su aportación más
importante a la industria la inversión
con el libro el inversor inteligente un
libro que de manera teórica agrupada los
mismos conceptos trataban de escribirte
análisis de la búsqueda de activos
infravalorados pero donde se le da mayor
peso al componente emocional y
psicológico para succionar las bolas del
esquizofrénico señor mercado
innegablemente aplicar hoy las
directrices de graham puede ser difícil
para conseguir valor de manera estricta
si aplicáramos sus premisas sería
prácticamente imposible conseguir una
buena compañía pero de manera holística
de nuevo si vemos a la inversión en
valor como sencillamente una estrategia
que nos permite buscar activos
infravalorados esta estrategia siempre
ha estado vigente y siempre lo estará
ahora si quisiéramos aplicar realmente
los principios del bario investing en
nuestro día a día es importante que
conozcamos la diferencia entre dos
conceptos fundamentalismos precio y
valor en un mercado eficiente en un
mercado ideal el precio que refleja un
activo suele ser una representación
fidedigna de su valor pero como suele
decir warren buffett preso en lo que
pagas y valoro que recibes entonces el
valor es muy subjetivo le voy a contar
una anécdota personal que pueda
ayudarnos a aterrizar un par de
conceptos interesantes en relación a
vale un best y hace unas tres semanas se
dañó mi televisor y
a mí verdaderamente me encantaba mi
televisor pero ahora sentía que si tenía
que gastar además dinero el tiempo en
buscarlo en estudiarlo etcétera tenía
que comprar algo o un modelo
relativamente superior le comento mi
conclusión a mi novia y ella me dice
mira me parece perfecta tu conclusión
pero siento que lo mejor que puedes
hacer es comprar algo básico y que
sencillamente funcione y así podemos
utilizar ese dinero para otro fin como
por ejemplo viajar desde mi percepción
como todo inversionista en valor esa
respuesta me dejó a mitad de camino a mí
me gusta comparar contraste píxeles el
color ver la distinta gama de
televisores comparar con la competencia
y si bien no soy un consumidor excesivo
el mismo soy verdaderamente un
aficionado acérrimos los deportes
difícilmente vea televisión al menos que
no sea un buen partido de fútbol de
basket o de béisbol entonces a pesar de
no ser un consumidor excesivo si es algo
importante
prefiero necesitarlo y tenerlo
a necesitarlo y tener que resolver a
última hora donde ver un real
madrid-barcelona al final me decidí por
un reciente modelo smrtv de muchísimo
pulgadas pero cuando le comenté a mi
novia cuánto me había costado realmente
la cara que puso fue terrible y estuvo
de muy mal humor durante toda la semana
ciertamente valga la cotación somos muy
cuidadosos con nuestros ahorros ambos
somos financieros ambos trabajamos en
los mercados y generalmente cada compra
que realizamos suele tener una buena
cuota y dosis de reflexión para elegir
la opción más contrastada entonces
podemos pensar que inicialmente ella
tenía razón porque gastar dinero en algo
que apenas usamos y de verdad es que
parece un derroche innecesario y suena
lógico cierto pero aunque ustedes no lo
crean este sencillo incidente por
decirlo de cierta forma enseña las
cuantas lecciones la primera es que lo
barato es diferente a lo infravalorado
no siempre tienes que ir a por lo barato
para darle mejor uso a tus ahorros al
final del día es cierto en algunos casos
en la mayoría posiblemente los baratos
pueden ser la mejor opción pero en lugar
de ir a por lo barato intenta ir por lo
infravalorado intenta ir por esa
relación precio/beneficio intenta ir por
el activo que te otorga el mayor valor
independientemente uno o sea el más
barato
al mercado como por ejemplo televisor
que compramos ciertamente no era el más
barato del mercado pero con base en sus
especificaciones en las consideraciones
que fueron tomadas en cuentas podemos
tener la certeza que va a ser la mejor
opción a largo plazo la segunda lección
que nos deja esta anécdota personal es
que es importante tener una visión a
largo plazo cuando se invierte en valor
parece mentira pero muchísimas personas
además de perder tiempo pierden mucho
dinero con una mentalidad cortoplacista
pensemos por ejemplo en warren buffett
quien para comprar una compañía en
versia hardware pasa muchísimo tiempo
meses evaluando estados financieros
ventajas competitivas y una serie de
consideraciones antes de tomar la
decisión pero una vez que toma esa
decisión pasa un solo día actuando y esa
decisión dura décadas como dicen aval
hay que jugar juegos a largo plazo con
personas a largo plazo porque la mejora
es cosa de la vida vienen del interés
compuesto
y pensando en esta anécdota personal y
en estas elecciones se mira la mente una
pregunta que siempre me hacen mis
clientes amigos y sobre todo nuestros
estudiantes y es es posible aplicar los
principios de val investing en venezuela
es posible invertir en valor y
ciertamente una pregunta difícil
considerando que estamos atravesando una
crisis severa en nuestro país ya son
ocho años continuos de contracción
económica pero cada vez que me toca
responder a esta pregunta
pienso que hay que recordar que la
inversión en valor no es solamente
comprar activos infravalorados que
cotizan en bolsa la inversión en valor
va desde una experiencia en la playa a
una ruta en bicicleta con tus amigos o
la lectura de un buen libro que puede
cambiar tu forma de ver las cosas como
me paso micro granja y con lynch al
final es adquirir una experiencia o una
acción que cotiza en bolsa por menos de
lo que vale y que te agregue mayor valor
a largo plazo
siendo concreto voy a intentar dar un
ejemplo financiero de lo que yo creo que
puede ser invertir en valor en
venezuela- y ciertamente este ejemplo es
algo jocoso y cada vez que se lo comento
a mis estudiantes ellos se ríen pero no
por esto no es del todo cierto y aquí va
una buena aplicación de val investing en
venezuela puede ser comprar una acción
de todas las empresas que cotizan en la
bolsa de lores de caracas asimismo como
lo oyen solamente una acción muchas
personas no lo saben pero de manera
directa cuando eres dueño y propietario
de una acción que cotiza en bolsa ya sea
en venezuela en japón o en eeuu te
conviertes en dueño de la compañía
literalmente de manera directa o
indirecta incluso a mayor o menor escala
eres beneficiario de lo que la compañía
haga o deje de hacer la mayoría de las
personas que participan en los mercados
financieros no entienden esto ven a las
acciones simplemente como tickets de
lotería o como pulsos electrónicos en
una tabla de cotización
la perspectiva holística y conservadora
la inversión en valor se basa en este
principio en tener un enfoque holístico
conservador pero sobre todo empresarial
hacia procesos de inversión pero
volviendo a nuestro ejemplo si compramos
hoy en día una acción de las 28 empresas
que cotizan en la bolsa valores de
caracas esa inversión no sería superior
a 30 y 35 dólares
se preguntarán ustedes cuál puede ser mi
super retorno invirtiendo solamente 35
horas en venezuela y la respuesta es que
al final no es un retorno completamente
monetario aquí estamos hablando un
retorno que va a nivel informativo
cultural y formativo en el momento en
que eran accionistas una empresa de
nuevo sean venezuela o en eeuu puedes
participar en sus asambleas anuales
escuchar de primera mano de su
presidente las distintas vicisitudes
disyuntivas a las cuales se ha
enfrentado la compañía el entorno
económico empresarial e incluso puedes
tomar parte de acción de los planes
estratégicos de negocio que la compañía
presenta de nuevo aquí el retorno no es
meramente monetario el retorno es
cultural es formativo y créanme que se
aprende mucho más en estos espacios
donde los empresarios que siguen de pie
en venezuela
intentando agregar valor a nuestro país
que en cualquier otro espacio de nuestra
sociedad y créanme que eso también es
invertir en valor
como idea final es innegable que el
mundo financiero tiene términos y
conceptos que parecen complejos y que
parecían o estaba incluso destinados al
ciudadano común afortunadamente este es
un concepto errado el estar
financieramente educado está al alcance
de cualquier venezolano
independientemente de su nivel educativo
y fue a raíz de esta premisa que nació
la escuela de inversión mi perspectiva
como su fundador era que poseer
conocimientos financieros es una de las
habilidades más poderosas que cualquier
venezolano puede tener y que esta
habilidad o esta destreza se hace
incluso mucho más imperativa tomando en
consideración que en nuestros hogares en
nuestras escuelas y en nuestras
universidades casi es inexistente
esto ocurre incluso considerando que
muchísimos venezolanos pasan muchísimos
problemas entendiendo la elaboración de
un presupuesto el manejo de una deuda la
planificación de una jubilación digna o
yéndonos un poco más allá en el
entendimiento básico del mercado de
valores
lo bueno es que la respuesta única
importante para salir del laberinto que
puede convertirse en no estar
financieramente educado es nuestra
educación
y es que como decimos en la escuela
todos los días el estar financieramente
educado es imprescindible para sortear
las bolas de la vida por último este
proyecto es nuestro grano de arena para
venezuela una sociedad donde sus
ciudadanos estén financieramente seguros
será mucho más prospera unos ciudadanos
que sepan tomar mejores decisiones en
relación a sus finanzas personales
tendrán mayores probabilidades de tener
una vida segura una sociedad donde sus
ciudadanos no se equivoquen tanto en
relación a sus ahorros en sus
inversiones podrán tener mejores
perspectivas a largo plazo al final es
importante que nos preguntemos cómo
podemos hacer para impartir mayor
educación financiera para poder cosechar
todos los beneficios que de ésta se
generan en el momento que cada uno de
los venezolanos estemos financieramente
seguros
nuestro país estará financieramente
seguro